روسيا وبيلاروسيا ليست اول الدول التي
تحرم من المشاركه رياضيا في العالم بسبب
الحرب في عام
1936 ظهرت حركه لمقاطعه برلين ايام الحكم
النازي لكنها فشلت بسبب رفض دمج السياسه
بالرياضه من قبل اللجنه الاولمبيه وشاركت
49 دوله وهو عدد فاقع عدد الفرق التي
شاركت في اي اولمبياد من قبل في عام 1948
ستبعدت المانيا واليابان من دوله الالعاب
الاولمبيه في لندن عقب نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وهزمتهما فيها وكان
للحرب البارده اثرها على الرياضه
الاولمبيه حيث انسحبت الولايات المتحده
واكثر من 60 من حلفائها من دوره العاب
موسكو لعام 1980 وفي عام
1984 كان الرد الروسي على الولايات
المتحده حيث سحبت هي وحلفائها ايضا
الاولمبياد لوس انجلوس كندا قوي على
واشنطن
[موسيقى]